et notre invité ce matin c'est le
général Vincent Desportes bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous monsieur vous
êtes avec nous pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse régionale et pour vous interroger
aujourd'hui à mes côtés Jefferson des
sports bonjour Jefferson bonjour Oriane
bonjour en général Jefferson spécialiste
des questions de défense pour le journal
Sud-Ouest général Vincent déporte
aujourd'hui débute les référendums
d'annexion voulu par Moscou dans les
quatre régions du crâne qui sont sous
contrôle russe quel incidence ça peut
avoir sur la guerre qu'est-ce que ça
peut changer dans cette guerre ça peut
changer beaucoup au moins théoriquement
quel est quel est le jeu de du président
Poutine c'est de repousser de 300 km
vers l'ouest la frontière à partir de
laquelle ses intérêts vitaux sont
attaqués et on connaît déjà évidemment
le résultat de ces de ces de ces
référendum donc à partir de la
proclamation des résultats on va se
trouver dans une situation nouvelle dans
lequel on va avoir des troupes
ukrainiennes qui n'ont pas à chercher ne
vont pas se battre pour l'Ukraine mais
vont attaquer la Russie donc on voit
bien que dans le droit russe parce que
pas plus que ça évidemment c'est
référendum nous serons reconnus par
personne et même les amis de Monsieur
Poutine on dit qu'ils ne le
reconnaîtraient pas on se trouve dans
une situation nouvelle qui donne un
droit théorique et purement russe au
président Poutine a utilisé les armes
nucléaires ce dont il a menacé le monde
d'ailleurs avant-hier donc on est dans
une situation nouvelle qui est
évidemment dangereuse et dont on ne
connaît pas encore évidemment le
résultat clairement la Russie pourra
dire qu'elle est attaquée y compris si
les attaques se font au sein de ce qui
est aujourd'hui l'Ukraine et c'est les
frontières ukrainiennes
il est clair que ce discours là
s'adresse essentiellement finalement à
la population un peu plus pour justifier
éventuellement le feu nucléaire mais
d'autre part la mobilisation c'est bien
votre pays qui est attaqué on revient
dans la grande guerre patriotique ce qui
justifie
la mobilisation alors je ne suis pas sûr
que la population russe soit
véritablement dupe de ce de ce jeu et on
voit bien que les réactions du peuple
russe montre bien qu'il n'allais pas
totalement à ses Hornets il y a une
surtout une accélération de calendrier
d'annexion en général parce que s'ils
étaient plutôt attendu début novembre là
cette accélération intervient après la
contre la contre-offensive ukrainienne
donc est-ce que vous y voyez un signe de
fébrilité quand on accélère ainsi le
calendrier et qu'on déclare la
mobilisation partielle dans le même
temps ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il y a un
lien direct entre le succès de la
contre-offensive ukrainienne qui a été
brillant et cela il fait quelque chose
pour parer les coûts quel est le
problème de du président Poutine c'est
qu'il doit gagner à peu près un mois
dans un mois un mois et demi les combats
vont s'arrêter le général hiver va
envoyer les gens dans les tranchées on
ne pourra plus avoir de grandes
offensives blindées et ça veut dire que
la météo va changer
c'est important de comprendre on est
dans une course au temps c'est à dire
que pour les Ukrainiens ils doivent
absolument gagner le pousser poussif
dans les cordes avant l'arrivée l'hiver
dont la contre-attaque donc la
contre-attaque au nord quant à Monsieur
Poutine il faut qu'il gagne un mois on
voit bien que militairement c'est où ça
n'est pas la débandade les analyses sont
un peu ont des avis divers sur cette
affaire-là
écoutez le mien c'est que l'armée russe
a perdu au nord est-ce qu'elle a perdu
dans les conditions honorables ou non
nonables je n'en sais rien mais ce qui
est sûr c'est que les Ukrainiens ont
fait un bon en avant absolument
expliquez-nous comment c'est possible de
faire une contre-offensive et de faire
un effet de surprise au moment où on a
quand même des satellites on a des
drones on a du service de renseignement
donc clairement les Ukrainiens ont
réussi à surprendre les Russes
commencent c'est possible expliquer nous
alors la différence essentielle
aujourd'hui on va bien c'est que il y a
une armée qui est bien meilleure que
l'autre et on voit bien là le résultat
de des aides américaines et anglaises
pendant pendant 8 ans on fait une
formation de formation on fait que
l'armée ukrainienne est capable de
choses dont on n'est plus capable depuis
longtemps l'armée russe donc il y a une
différence de compétence importante
on sait bien que cette guerre est basée
sur des erreurs d'interprétation de
Poutine dont deux énormes il n'y a pas
que ça c'est pas les seuls la première
c'est l'Ukraine n'existe pas donc son
armée n'existe pas son armée n'est pas
n'est pas meilleure qu'en 2014 et ça
c'était parfaitement faux et d'autre
part sa croyance en sa propre armée et
la pensant susceptible en trois jours
puisque c'était le point de de
l'emporter donc les erreurs
d'interprétation et alors pour continuer
les la grande force on le sait les
Ukrainiens c'est qu'ils sont inondés
d'informations
occidentale et essentiellement
américaine donc ils ont un avantage
comparatif si vous permettez
l'expression tout à fait important les
services de renseignement occidentaux
aide l'Ukraine à préparer ses opérations
c'est pour ça que quand le président
Poutine avant-hier 10 et c'est l'OTAN
qui m'attaque évidemment il a tort
puisque l'OTAN n'a jamais tiré un seul
obus en Russie mais en même temps il est
clair que on est dans une une pro
chinoise comme les américains on a quand
même le camp occidental avec des soldats
Ukrainiens qui se battent même contre la
Russie en ceci évidemment il a il a
raison et sans l'aide
occidentale il est évidemment clair que
l'Ukraine serait tombé extrêmement
rapidement aurait peut-être tenu
quelques jours et mais mais les affaires
seraient serait terminé bien évidemment
et c'est donc cette la plus-value
ukrainienne elle est quand même
profondément
occidentale aujourd'hui c'est l'Ukraine
qui est en position de force sur le
terrain qu'est-ce qu'on s'est
précisément de selon vous selon vos
informations de la situation de l'armée
russe
c'est que elle a de grandes difficultés
elle a eu on l'a vu de très grandes
difficultés à attaquer à prendre
grignotant jour par jour dans ces dans
ces attaques elle dans le dans le dans
le dans dans la région de louance et
puis de donner ce qu'elle a annoncé
alors que on a vu brutalement l'armée
ukrainienne avancée l'armée l'armée
russe a de à de graves problèmes de de
logistique de graves problèmes
d'armement on sait qu'en gros pour une
image qui est à peu près juste l'armée
russe a perdu en matériel à peu près
tout ce qu'elle avait engagé le 24
février dernier donc il y a presque 8
mois maintenant un jour près à 7 mois à
un jour près elle a perdu tout ça
ensuite on elle a des problèmes
d'organisation et les preuves de
commandement toute chose qui existe
beaucoup moins dans l'armée ukrainienne
qui s'est complètement transformé après
les affaires du don-basse en 2014 et
puis une armée c'est d'abord une volonté
de combattre et on sait bien que là on
est dans une inégalité une asymétrie
extrêmement forte les Ukrainiens se
battent pour leur propre existence
l'existence même de cet état nation qui
commence à naître qui commence à naître
qui de ces cristalliser véritablement
depuis 2014 alors que les Russes on
comprend bien dans les rues et les
grandes villes russes aujourd'hui les
Russes ne comprennent pas ce qu'est
cette guerre et ils n'ont pas le
sentiment de se battre pour leur terre
d'où d'ailleurs les faits
ible à mon avis quand même improbable du
du président que souhaite le président
Poutine de voir les Russes considérés
que le Dombasle est à eux et donc de
créer ce sentiment d'être attaqué chez
les Russes mais bon je crois évidemment
que c'est un pari qui est d'ores et déjà
perdu sur les livraisons d'armes Vincent
des sports qu'est-ce que on peut dire
parce que on sait qu'elles sont massives
il y a des pièces d'artillerie des
missiles en t-shirts des véhicules
blindés la France a livré 18 annoncésar
et sur la table là on voit dans les
discussions que les Américains
pourraient peut-être livrer des chars
Abraham alors vous qui venez des blindés
qui avait commandé une brigade de
Charles Leclerc est-ce que ce type de
véhicule blindé ça pourrait faire la
différence notamment pour repousser les
Russes parce que la France peut
peut-être envoyer des chars Leclerc à ce
que ça ça fait partie des discussions
est-ce que c'est possible alors il y a
deux choses différentes dans un premier
temps il est clair que dans cette guerre
ce sont bien les blindés qui attaquent
qui prennent le terrain et l'infanterie
qui occupent quelque part on revient à
la guerre que nous avions cru nous
disparu c'était on pensait que c'était
terminé ça ce type de compenser que
c'était terminé et on revient la vérité
de la guerre la guerre elle elle sur le
terrain un moment donné il faut bien
qu'il est soldats qui portent mon
uniforme qui attaquent sous blindage qui
prennent le terrain et qui le tiennent
la guerre revient à sa vérité qu'on
avait cru oublier ça c'est un premier
point il est clair que les chars font la
différence la deuxième chose est-ce que
nous nous pouvons donner des chars
Leclerc et bien honnêtement j'en doute
pourquoi les américains ont des milliers
d'Europe ont des milliers d'abrahams les
l'armée française a peut-être au maximum
dans ces stocks de sang Charles clercs
dont je dirais une moitié qui fonctionne
contenu des dégradations de nos stocks
de pièces entraîné par la dégradation
des budgets militaires depuis 25 ans
donc on a déjà donné un tiers de nos
Césars je suis pas sûr qu'il faille
donner encore un tiers de nos Charles
Leclerc qui nous resterait en gros et
qui me laisserait avec un régiment en
état de fonctionner en France je dirais
ce serait pas raisonnable mais ce qui
prouve aussi en creux qu'il est temps
que l'armée française prenne en compte
la réalité de la guerre et c'est qui à
nouveau et à nouveau des stocks qui
permettent de tenir un certain temps
dans la guerre qui revient et qui est
une guerre un peu peut-être à l'ancienne
peut-être mais si cette guerre là qui
revient cette guerre que nous avons crue
morte et donc nous deux
nous sommes devenus une force de police
internationale excellente remarquable
l'armée française est la meilleure armée
européenne sans conteste dans ce genre
de mission mais nous sommes pas une
armée prête à la guerre de demain d'où
les mesures qui s'endorment et déjà
prises par le gouvernement nous
écoutions le ministre le corps nu parler
et le président Macron permet d'économie
de guerre la nécessité d'accélérer le
rythme de production d'armement la
nécessité de multiplier les chaînes de
production pour reconstituer les stocks
et être capable si la guerre vient ça
prend du temps ça prend du temps c'est
bien c'est bien une guerre ça prend du
temps manifestants ça prend du temps
aujourd'hui on met trois ans pour faire
un canon César les mesures qui sont
prises c'est pourtant on va faire un
canon César en un an il faut avoir plus
de chaînes de production d'obus etc nous
la France doit se repréparer à la guerre
qui existe et qui peut venir ne pensons
pas que cette guerre là elle va
s'arrêter que ce sera terminée et que
nous pourrons nous européens nous
rendormir dans l'illusion que nous avons
tué la guerre dans la guerre il existe
elle existe tout autour de nous et à
force de croire que la guerre était
morte mais la guerre vient et dans sa
forme la plus brutale la plus la plus
ignoble c'est la guerre que les Russes
font aujourd'hui en Ukraine sur la
occidentale est-ce qu'il y a un risque
qu'elle s'épuise l'excédentale vers
l'Ukraine avec un mot les Occidentaux ne
soient plus en capacité de fournir des
armées l'Ukraine il y a pas un risque
c'est une réalité c'est à dire que on
sait que les flux financiers et les flux
d'armement ont diminué au cours de l'été
pour une raison extrêmement simple c'est
que pour l'instant les armées
occidentales ont puisé sur le stock mais
en gros elles sont et qui étaient
extrêmement faibles dans le cas de
l'armée française est une armée sans
stock parce que les stocks du défilent
pas le 14 juillet donc c'est pas c'est
pas grave ne pas les garder donc je te
dis on se rend compte que c'est une
erreur mais ce qu'on ce qu'on pouvait
donner de nos stocks de nos obus pour
l'artillerie par exemple il faut bien
qu'une armée et des obus et bien on est
allé à peu près au bout c'est vrai pour
nous c'est vrai pour la majorité des
pays c'est vrai aussi pour les
Américains dont on dit je ne sais pas
qu'ils ont donné presque les deux tiers
de leur missile Stinger on sait bien que
les Américains c'est pas leur guerre ça
il la font conduire et quelque part ça
les arrange cette guerre qui affaiblit
la Russie mais la guerre qu'il prépare
c'est pas celle-là c'est la guerre
contre la Chine celle-là il y croit et
donc ils ne peuvent pas se dégarnir
complètement donc eux aussi ont besoin
de reconstituer leur stock de relancer
leur machine à produire de l'armement
pour continuer à aider lucrètes parce
que ça il faut le faire évidemment mais
aussi eux pour être prêt au conflit
auquel ils croient qui est la guerre
entre la Chine et eux aussi pour savoir
aussi pour pour les Russes sur le stock
d'armement parce qu'on voit que eux
aussi consomment beaucoup beaucoup de
munitions et qu'à un moment il va
falloir qu'il compte est-ce que vous
pensez que ça aussi il y a un
affaiblissement en tout cas la Russie va
devoir faire aussi mieux gérer ses
stocks et en tout cas ils ont puisé
dedans alors ça c'est c'est clair c'est
que il y a une possibilité de
[Musique]
doivent le comprendre et je pense qu'il
faut être clair dans le discours
politique même je pense qu'il est
important d'établir le rapport entre
notre propre liberté qui est défendue
par des soldats très courageux qui sont
Ukrainiens dans le dos basque et et
notre et notre propre liberté à nous je
crois qu'il faut être clair le dire et
le redire parce que les Français sont en
train d'oublier cette affaire là cette
guerre c'est une vieille guerre on ne
comprend pas mais cette guerre c'est
quand même la défense de notre propre
liberté à nous de notre démocratie et
évidemment le petit prix que nous payons
vaut infiniment le coup et l'information
de cette semaine c'est aussi cette
mobilisation partielle décrétée par
Vladimir Poutine un 300 000 réservistes
est-ce que ça c'est le signe que
Vladimir Poutine est dans un état de
faiblesse est aux abois est-ce que ça
peut changer quelque chose dans la
guerre
c'est un signe de faiblesse c'est un
signe de faiblesse Poutine a dit qu'il
ne mobiliserait pas parce qu'il ne veut
il ne voulait pas que ce fut une guerre
mais juste une opération militaire
spéciale donc il avoue sa faiblesse il
avoue sa faiblesse alors est-ce que ça
va jouer la réponse pas beaucoup et
sûrement pas tout de suite
300000 mais 300 000 hommes on se rend
pas compte mais entraîner 300.000 hommes
c'est gigantesque mon compliqué et ça
demande vous pouvez pas avoir en même
temps une armée au front et une armée
qui entraîne une armée qui va venir donc
ça va être très compliqué il y a des
problèmes logistiques du mobilisation
cette mobilisation est d'après ce qu'on
comprend désorganiser est organisé par
les eaux blast c'est pas au niveau pas
au niveau central on ne sait pas
exactement qui va mobiliser qui et
ensuite il va falloir entraîner pour
former un bataillon en infanterie qui se
tient bah il faut trois ou quatre mois
si vous voulez ou cinq mois ou 6 mois et
donc on voit bien que cette réserve quoi
qu'il arrive n'aura aucun résultat
tactique avant le printemps ça c'est
absolument sûr d'où la nécessité de
Monsieur Poutine de faire peur aux
occidentaux pour gagner ce mois qui qui
reste sur la peur justement il a aussi à
brandi de nouveau la menace de
l'utilisation d'une arme nucléaire
tactique qu'est-ce que comme on le prend
est-ce qu'il faut le prendre au sérieux
c'est pas la première fois c'est
toujours dans cet escalade de la peur
cette menace écoutez je crois qu'il faut
toujours prendre au sérieux quelqu'un
qui a tout moment peut appuyer sur le
bouton nucléaire c'était un peu oublié
par les Français parce que ça aussi on
croit j'entends des commentateurs dire
mais non la rue nucléaire est faite pour
ne pas être utilisée évidemment pas
c'est la dissuasion c'est l'arme
nucléaire elle est faite pour être
utilisée et c'est bien par la menace de
l'emploi que qu'on dissuade d'agir et
c'est exactement ce que fait monsieur
Poutine il dit moi je suis sérieux il
dit ça n'est pas du bluff quand il le
dit d'ailleurs il s'affaiblit mais ça
n'est pas du bluff moi j'ai puré et je
le ferai si j'ai besoin or il le fera
s'il est véritablement acculé c'est là
vous y croyez à cette perspective j'y
crois complètement moi j'y crois
complètement mettez un chien enragé au
bout du couloir qui sait que s'il ne
vous aide pas la gorge il va mourir il
va vous sauter à la gorge et c'est bien
le problème et le problème actuel c'est
qu'il y a pas de solution on est on est
il y a pas de solution acceptable pour
Monsieur Poutine parce qu'il joue sa
mort et la mort du sans régime lui-même
il y a pas de solution acceptable pour
Monsieur et inscrit et son peuple
parce qu'il joue leur propre existence
donc aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
solution donc il faudrait qu'un
changement de paradigme à un moment
donné il faudra qu'une révolution qui
change dans le jeu pour que l'équation
change mais est-ce que déjà le fait que
l'opinion là il y a des départs massifs
de Russie cette semaine depuis l'annonce
de cette mobilisation partielle il y a
également des Russes qui descendent dans
la rue est-ce que le changement
d'opinion ça ça peut jouer dans cette
guerre et ça peut jouer contre Vladimir
Poutine bien sûr ça peut jouer c'est
indisément le changement de paradigme
pour moi c'est quelque chose qui change
totalement le jeu pour l'instant le jeu
est bloqué on n'est pas comme on dirait
en Russie quand on joue aux échecs
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut une révolution
de palais ou alors il faut une
révolution dans la rue où il faut que
nous on arrête totalement pour des
raisons que je connais pas encore de
soutenir l'Occident et alors on aura un
déséquilibre qui va se créer à un
endroit ou un autre mais pour l'instant
on n'est pas et on est clair que
Monsieur Poutine fait est obligé fait un
pari aujourd'hui mais c'est un pari un
pari risqué moi j'aime bien une
expression américaine il vient il est
dans la fuite en avant parce qu'il est
acculé et parce qu'il est mais celui qui
est dans la fuite en avant est encore
plus dangereux que celui qui a encore de
bonnes chances de tenir j'aime bien une
expression américaine j'ai vécu
longtemps aux Etats-Unis qui dit when
you wind hole stop digging quand vous
êtes dans le trou arrêtez de creuser
mais il continue à creuser est-ce que
c'est ça tombe ou la nôtre personne ne
sait et pendant ça va au fur et à mesure
que l'armée ukrainienne libère des
territoires on découvre des charniers
des crimes de guerre est-ce que la
menace de poursuite devant la Cour de
justice internationale ne rend pas
encore plus difficile une solution à ce
conflit alors oui et non oui et non
parce que nous n'irons personne n'ira
chercher monsieur Poutine au Kremlin
pour l'amener au tribunal et et Monsieur
Poutine rejette cette justice
puisqu'elle est une justice occidentale
vous pouvez brandir pourquoi y a-t-il
une Nuremberg en 46 et 47 ou 45 et 46 ou
les criminels nazis terrible terrible
ont été ont été jugés c'est parce que
nous avions détruit totalement l'armée
c'était la mission qui avait les éner
quand il remarqué il est allé à Berlin
en fait c'est les Russes et il a détruit
totalement l'armée allemande mais ce ne
se passera pas et donc personne n'ira
chercher s'ils survit monsieur Boutin la
petite cuillère pour le juger donc on
jugera quelques prisonniers qu'on aura
pris mais évidemment monsieur Poutine ne
croit pas et lutte contre le droit
occidental et la main mise l'Occident ça
ne aucune raison de lui faire peur il
n'y a que les gens qui ne comprennent
pas le rapport entre la force et le
droit qui croit que cette menace peut
avoir une influence sur le président
Poutine dans cette guerre on a aussi les
paramètres paramilitaires de Wagner
est-ce que ça change la donne parce
qu'on a des mercenaires les soldats ont
quand même un code d'honneur on a vu ces
massacres autour de 18 avec ses tombes
retrouvées parce que là l'emploi de
mercenaire ça prouve là encore les
difficultés de Poutine sachant que
Wagner est aussi déployé au Mali par
ailleurs non mais clairement clairement
quand on voit alors c'est pas si c'est
vrai mais quand on voit les recrutements
qui se font dans les auprès des
mendiants dans les hôpitaux
psychiatriques etc tout ça est une
preuve de faiblesse donc c'est un homme
qui est acculé encore une fois les
hommes acculés sont encore plus
dangereux que les hommes qui ne sont pas
mais oui donc on va aller vers des
crimes de guerre de plus en plus
important et quand vous mettez des gens
que vous que vous que vous avez juste
mobilisé vous les avez pas formés vous
savez en France les soldats sont de
grandes qualités ces gens qui ont qui
ont travaillé qui ont fait des des
études pour la moitié d'entre eux
jusqu'au bac donc c'est quand même bien
mais on passe un temps fou aller former
alors apprendre le droit à leur
apprendre l'éthique il est clair que ça
n'est pas la priorité l'armée française
est une armée éthique parce qu'on
travaille là-dessus il est clair que la
mérite n'est pas une armée éthique et en
plus c'est une armée qui n'est pas
encadrée en ce sens il n'y a pas de
sous-officier les sous-officiers c'est
le corps c'est la colonne vertébrale
d'une armée il y en a pas et donc le
soldat finalement qui voit la violence
déployer tous les jours au sein même de
ses unités bah ne n'a aucune hésitation
pour déployer la violence parce qu'il
n'est pas tenu ni par son encadrement ni
par les des des
de l'éthique qu'on aurait pu lui
insuffler pendant sa formation vous
disiez qu'il faudrait un changement de
paradigme pour retrouver une issue à ce
conflit est-ce que le fait que les
Chinois appellent au CC de feu à travers
le dialogue ça c'est un tournant bien
écoutez oui et non puisque ça fait
longtemps c'est de faire la selle
dépense c'était le sommet de
saint-marcande il y a donc maintenant
cette huit jours je crois et là Monsieur
Poutine a raté une occasion c'était
l'occasion il aurait pu faire un deal
avec ses copains l'Indien le Chinois et
les autres ok bon je vais arrêter parce
que tout le monde la Chine qui le
soutenait maintenant on commence à dire
bon ça va bien parce que mes routes de
la soie moi elles sont bloquées moi il
faut que je fasse du business quand même
et donc effectivement il aurait pu la
faire un deal avec ses copains dis ok
vous me reconnaissez ce que j'ai piqué
j'arrête là on arrête tout et là les
autres les l'Indien le chinois le
les et ses copains d'Azerbaïdjan aurait
dit ok euh ils sont pas c'est pas
complètement les copains les armes les
gens mais il aurait dit ok on fait ce
dit mais là il a raté ça c'est-à-dire
que il a pas tenu compte pour l'instant
puisque sa déclaration est postérieure
et il continue dans la fuite en avant et
quelque part il est prisonnier de
lui-même il est prisonnier de ses
erreurs et il craint directement pour sa
vie il est dans un moment où il joue
pour sa propre survie ça nous rappelle
quand même Hitler ça nous rappelle
Hitler au fond de son bunker qui
continue à demander au berlinois de se
mobiliser et d'aller lutter contre les
chars soviétiques c'est surtout c'est le
régime de l'avenir Poutine qui est
menacé aujourd'hui et il est menacé il
est menacé très directement c'est bien
ça on sait que le pouvoir change en
Russie par des révolutions de palais
qu'on sent mal nous le coup de chef bref
il y a le film on sent pas trop ce qui
se passe mais ça se passe ça se passe
comme ça donc lui et d'ailleurs
peut-être que la les chutes inopinées
des oligarques est liée en quelque sorte
à ce sentiment qu'à le président Poutine
d'être sur la fin de sa trajectoire lui
qui espérait être le grand vainqueur le
24 février au matin il s'est mis dans
une situation dans lequel il y a pas il
y a pas d'ISS la folie il y a pas de
sortie et en plus il ne sait pas saisir
les occasions de pour terminer cette
affaire là non pas au mieux mais au
moins mal un dernier mot général des
sports est-ce que pour vous aujourd'hui
on peut savoir qu'ils sont les gagnants
qui sont les perdants de ce conflit
écoutez oui alors le perdant majeur
évidemment c'est c'est la Russie et pour
et pour des décennies les gagnants ce
sont les États-Unis qui trouvent sur un
plateau l'affaiblissement de la Russie
en même temps et puis
l'accroissement de leur de leur capacité
à dominer à dominer l'Europe
l'Angleterre également qui poursuit sa
longue tradition séculaire qui est
d'éviter qu'un qu'une grande puissance
installe sur le continent d'où les
manœuvres bilatérales de Boggio ça sa
volonté de créer une espèce de
commonwell c'est à nouveau Commonwealth
anti-européen derrière donc ça c'est les
c'est les gagnants de la Chine étaient
gagnantes mais elle a compris que là le
pays qui perd le pays enfin il y a deux
éléments de entités qui perdent il y a
l'Europe d'abord alors oui elle s'est
resserrée mais elle s'est resserrée sous
une tutelle américaine de plus en plus
appuyée l'industrie d'armement
européenne est en train de perdre
puisqu'on achète là-bas et le pays qui
est en train de perdre et ça ça
m'inquiète c'est la France pourquoi
parce que la France était centrale en
Europe avec l'Allemagne désormais la
nouvelle géographie à 35 à 36 de la de
l'Europe fait que la France devient
marginalisée
géographiquement et que d'autre part ce
qui faisait le pilier l'Europe c'était
le couple franco-allemand et les
dernières déclarations du Chancel des
choses sont extrêmement inquiétantes
parce qu'il affirme que maintenant
l'Europe ça va être lui la défense de
l'Europe c'est lui et ce couple
franco-allemand sur lequel nous
comptions beaucoup pour arriver à
construire cette cette Europe des
nations bah ce couple là est en train de
s’effilocher et c'est peut-être une des
plus mauvaises nouvelles de cette guerre
merci beaucoup générale Vincent
Desportes merci pour cet entretien
passionnant et d'avoir été avec nous
pour nous éclairer sur cette situation
de faire ça on regarde la ligne de
Sud-Ouest environnement face à la peur
c'est à la Une de votre journal merci de
faire ça merci
[Musique]